[Music]
no other song for this one an unlikely
meeting took place this week between two
strangers
separated by an ocean of time and space
jamie yukas has the story a voyage that
began here on the coast of rhode island
in 2018
concluded here in portugal's azores
islands last week
it's where 17-year-old christian santos
found a message
sealed in a plastic bottle what did it
say
it's dead it was thanksgiving he was 13
and he was visiting visiting family in
rhode island
and he was from vermont that 13 year old
is now
16 year old sean smith he and his
relatives tossed several bottles in the
ocean that day
back in 2018. a couple of them got found
not long afterwards but then two and a
half years later
i had completely forgotten we had even
done it the bottle traveled more than 3
thousand miles across the atlantic ocean
from rhode island to the azores after
christian put the word out he'd found
the message
sean saw a news report about it on
wednesday night
my first reaction was what the heck
the two teenagers have more in common
than their age
christian is also a native new englander
born in massachusetts before moving to
the azores
a coincidence not lost on his mom molly
they said christian
do you realize this is like really close
to where we were from honey
what are the chances of him finding this
bottle
and knowing how to speak and read
english
if it was somebody else who didn't
they'd probably just toss it
it's kicked off a friendship i think we
will stay in touch
pretty special currency so you want to
have a real friendship out of this
of course of course
of course a friendship that's worth the
wait
for cbs this morning saturday i'm jamie
yukis
sounds like mom wants to have a friend
whatever mom says follow mom